May is National Nurse's Month,
a time to honor these special humans
who have dedicated their lives to helping other people.
And in honor of National Nurse's Month
we wanted to do a little something special
for a nurse who wanted some beauty advice.
Oh gosh! Do I love beauty and all things beauty!
Take a look.
(audience applauding)
Hi, my name's Katherine Altieri,
and I'm from Staten Island, New York.
I'm an intensive care nurse
at Staten Island University Hospital.
I initially majored in music
and never really thought about becoming a nurse
but I was inspired by my brother, Dan,
who is also a nurse at the same hospital.
I work 12 hour shifts, four days a week.
When I'm at work, I'm a plain Jane.
I wear no makeup and I have my hair up in a bun.
When I'm outside of work I go full glam.
Think winged eyeliner, shimmery eyeshadow
and false eyelashes.
My husband jokes around with me
that I either look like I'm ready to walk the red carpet
or like I just rolled out of bed.
Drew, can you help a nurse out?
I'd love to learn to get an everyday look
that's natural, quick and easy
and doesn't take too much time to do
and makes me feel beautiful inside and out of the hospital.
(audience cheering)
I so relate. I really do.
I think we all, a lot of us live in extremes.
I feel like I get very together for work,
and then in real life, it's a hot mess.
So boy, does this speak to me!
And this morning we worked with my friends at Maybelline,
along with their amazing makeup artists, Jenna Christina
to show Catherine how to get that every day look.
So, let's check that out.
Hi, ladies!
Hi!
Hi, Drew.
I am so excited to be doing this with you.
Jenna and Catherine, I am thrilled.
So, Catherine normally likes to do nothing
or go all the way.
So today we're gonna scale her back
and do a more natural makeover,
something that's approachable to wear every day.
Catherine, why do you think that you're an extremist?
'Cause I am too. I'm very all or nothing.
But why are you like that?
You know what, I feel like it's almost like an alter ego.
Nurse by day, rockstar by night.
That's really kind of me in a nutshell.
I am a makeup junkie through and through.
Yes.
I always have been.
I grew up in a makeup chair as a little girl
and I watched women transform and stand more empowered,
and to me, that's what beauty is, it's a feeling.
And I'd love to know what you're planning on doing today.
I'm gonna do a makeover on Catherine
using Maybelline New York's Green Edition.
It's high performing makeup,
with a high percentage of natural origin ingredients.
The packaging is made with up to 95% recycled material,
and the formulas are clean and vegan.
We all have our eyes open to how important being eco
and green and planet friendly.
So, I applaud Maybelline for this line.
This is really beautiful.
I'm going back in
with the lighter shade right under your eyes
to brighten it up.
If you put one shade all over your face
then you're just flattening it.
So, there's no depth or dimension.
Exactly!
A little highlighter, a little contour,
a little something lighter under the eyes,
a little something darker on the jawline.
'Cause I lost my jawline a few years ago.
It just took off.
Oh my God! I hope you find her one day.
I don't think so.
I think she went on permanent vacation.
(Jena and Catherine laughing)
Okay, so next, it's buildable volume.
So, if you want a natural look, you can put one coat on.
If you want a little bit more volume,
you can just add a couple more.
This is really nice because it has mango oil in it.
It has lasting hydration.
Your lips are going to feel and look really smooth.
And I really need this
because I'm just in a mask all day,
and I'm super dry all the time.
So, we're gonna do a big reveal on the stage.
I'm so excited to do that with you guys.
Catherine, are you feeling good about that?
Yes, and my hair's not gonna be in a bun for once.
You're gonna style it and come out full force?
I'm gonna actually,
literally let my hair down and figuratively.
I am gonna be out there waiting for you,
ready to embrace you and show you off.
And Jenna, I'm so excited to see what you're gonna do
with this extraordinary line.
I can't wait to see everything.
(upbeat music)